hey guys this is the Reuben report I'm
former House Majority Leader Dave Rubin
and I have two of my favorite guests
with me whitney mixter and jacqueline
Glenn
they were together just about a month
ago and I've brought them back because
the fans demanded it and we've got a lot
to talk about
I don't you heard there was an election
last night and this thing was a freaking
bloodbath for the Democrats a red
wedding if you will it was just a
disaster if you're a fan of the
Democrats if you're a Republican you're
feeling pretty good today but there was
a lot of stuff that happened and we want
to just kind of do something simple with
it just talk about five things that
happened last night so we've even put
together a nice little little image for
you take a look okay so these are the
these are the big five things that I
think happened last night the Democrats
and we even put them in blue because the
Democrats are blue everybody knows that
they lost the Senate the Republicans now
control the Senate the Republicans
elected an african-american senator in
the south Tim Scott who already was a
senator from South Carolina but he had
been appointed because someone stepping
down
he was now elected in the South the
black Republican in the south DC is
getting recreational marijuana which the
Democrats are gonna need after this
election Massachusetts got an out LGBT
attorney general by the name of Maura
Healey and the short-term consequences
probably aren't that huge because DC is
gonna remain ice for the last two years
of Obama's presidency so basically the
Republicans weren't giving him any bills
to work with in the first place now they
can double down on that he may be forced
to do some executive orders etc etc okay
so instead of CNN and MSNBC and Fox just
babbling on 24 hours a day about this
let's just do some simple stuff how do
you feel this morning with me I feel
great about the images that were just
shown on that in terms of color coding
the color was really good really
but I feel like the world is just being
turned upside down African Americans or
Republican VC is smoking weed there's a
gay person as an attorney general like I
don't know what's next but I can't wait
to see it everything is turned upside
down I'm very disheveled mentally this
morning all right well we'll work with
that disheveled mentally Jacqueline how
do you feel about what happened last
night I'm frustrated you know it's just
the whole situation kind of just sucks I
mean this is like the worst Congress in
a long time they have like what a 90
percent disapproval or something but
they had that many you know being
reelected so people obviously aren't
trying to change many things yeah is the
fault here I I think a lot of the fault
is that the Democrats they all ran away
from Obama
I've given Obama a ton of [ __ ] on this
show people get angry on the left at me
because I've given Obama [ __ ] but that
they all ran away from him you know they
said they would that woman who wouldn't
say whether she voted for him or not
they wouldn't you know they didn't want
to double down on Obamacare etcetera it
said don't they think maybe they should
have just stuck with their guy and that
at least would have got the base going
all right we'll come out I mean
Democrats are running away from
themselves in general like their that
nobody wants to have anything to do with
them even Hillary Clinton you know who's
the only real hopeful for 2016 they're
like oh look at Hillary sided with all
the losers you know they're like
pigeon-hole they're just completely
ostracizing their own here and and it's
all I don't know if it's all related to
Obama but it seems like we just don't
have a chance anymore
yeah so as a person that's down with
science I know you like that science
don't you you love that time do you fear
that like so on issues like climate
change things like that stem-cell
research etc etc that that to me if I
was someone in your shoes and I'm a
science believer myself so I'm someone
in my shoes I'm in my own shoes right
now that that that to me is the scary
part that the Republicans might try to
roll back some of this stuff social
issue is in jeopardy whenever
Republicans are in control you know that
is always my biggest fear but to be
honest like I'm not sure that that much
is actually going to change because in
my opinion both parties are kind of
ruled by business
and like you said Democrats are running
away from the party but it's it's like
that on both sides because no one really
wants to identify as a party because
both of them are just you know terrible
yeah where were the independence
everyone keeps saying oh the
independence the there's this third
group of people that nobody talks about
I don't identify I'm not a Democrat and
I'm not a Republican like where is that
group of people I mean the libertarians
were the the real third party in this
election I feel like and they were just
it always happens or they just pull our
they pull the Democrat vote really away
and I mean I don't think that that would
have made a huge difference in making
the Senate you know Democrat but but it
doesn't help that's for sure how are we
about to see the worst of the worst
because when I think now how these
couple years have been so gridlocked and
right I think they think Congress had a
seven percent approval rating or
something like that and Obama is already
he was already saying two weeks ago he's
gonna start with the executive actions
on immigration and stuff like it forever
yeah he's been delaying immigration he's
been delaying Keystone like he just
keeps pushing things back doesn't tell
you how [ __ ] up the system is that
what he's saying is I know if I do this
stuff before an election it's gonna hurt
my guys so I'm actually gonna
preemptively tell you what I'm gonna do
so that I don't hurt my people but then
I'm gonna do it anyway so it's a it's
like everybody's at fault alright so
he's being strategic about it because I
think with Keystone for example like
he's been wanting to do that for a long
time yeah but now that the Republicans
are in office he can be like well look
the Republicans made me do it you know
so he's going to be able to get out of
that a little bit but I mean it's like
that on both sides so t-shirts now that
said the Republicans made me do it
because for a long time the Republicans
have been wanting to lower Social
Security and now Obama's probably gonna
compromise and do that and then all the
Republicans but all the Republicans are
gonna be like oh look at this liberal
socialist Marxist dictator lowering all
of our Social Security when in actuality
it's been the Republicans pushing it all
along so it's just gonna be like a blame
war who's you know who's gonna get
blamed for doing them
that's the real war that we have every
day is the blame war what does it say
about Obama that he won two elections
but the two midterms that he was in
office for his party got crushed I mean
really both were distracted like does
that show that kind of my feelings like
I kind of like him like I would love to
play basketball with him and have a
drink with him and smoke a joint with
him but as far as a president at this
point and now he really is a lame duck
like now it's official lame duck season
but what does that say about him like
people I think like him or like the idea
of him more than what actually is going
on I think that's initially what got him
into office not saying he you know he's
very well-spoken and he's an intelligent
guy but he got elected because he was
charismatic and people were related to
him and wanted to kick it with him like
a homie you know yeah I knew you were I
was just smelling your room but now now
that we're really into nitty-gritty
politics all these years later we're
like that was another idea yeah do you
feel the same way that it was more about
like the idea of him and the hope and
change guy and the rainbows and the
excitement and then yeah he made a lot
of promises that he didn't necessarily
follow through on so I mean I don't
blame people like we if we just got out
of being you know with Bush for years
and people wanted something great people
want to change and he represented that
for a lot of people so the thing is Bush
didn't do any good and I didn't want to
hang out with him so at least we have
one redeeming factor Yale or wherever he
went I think it was yellow okay let's
move on so if you were watching the
election there were also all these
reports of electoral fraud all kinds of
stuff and we are in a digital age now
where it seems to me that it's just
going to get a lot easier to manipulate
the system and for fraud to happen so
down in North Carolina people that claim
they were voting for democratic a Hagan
said that their votes were being flipped
to the Republican candidate and then
this video popped up of actually the
reverse happening so let's take a look
okay that seems pretty obvious what's
happening they're trying to vote for the
Republican candidate and it is being
selected on the Democratic candidate you
know every year these things keep
popping up more and more now that we're
doing this all electronically how much
do you believe in the system that's what
I kept thinking like forgot forget
whether it's happening to Republicans or
the Democrats cuz I know people only get
excited when it's there guys being
screwed so forgetting that like how much
you actually believe that it's the
results that we get are actually legit
first I would like to ask it's do I live
in like some weird like some pocket
because for me I had like the little
thing where I punched the whole old
school I was like retro I was vintage
cord yeah actually tap it and yeah I
mean I didn't get that at all but I mean
a hundred percent I think that when
you're dealing with anything
technologically based and then politics
and big money I never trust it I will
never trust it that is no yeah I mean
okay so we have saw that look that's
sort of anecdotal and I guess someone
could have maybe had their finger on
another part of the screen to manipulate
it just to make people go nuts but do
you trust that the system is actually
working properly no I mean I'm from
Florida
I've seen it time and time again that we
just don't know how to count yeah and
apparently we don't know how to you know
use computers either so I'm not
surprised
yeah so Florida went down the governor
race went down really close and Charlie
Crist I hate these two men I mean I
don't know that there's a race where I
hated to people more Rick Scott who I
believe in nothing that he believes in
and Charlie Crist who absolutely
believes in nothing and has taken every
position on everything I think he has
some issues with the gay community
perhaps you want to enlighten if you
know what I'm saying I don't know if you
want to you have just they're nodding of
your head there's enough there it
wouldn't be my first choice for
resigning and unless it was like Miami
name you know yeah so as we go more
digital with this stuff is this just
gonna happen more and more like this to
me seems like one thing where we should
be going back to the punch cards and
paper trail so that after they can
actually count something I mean
anyway the wind blows like paper trail I
mean people can lose ballots they can
things can happen
I mean you pallet the political system
the voting system you always have to
consider there's most likely a huge
margin of error going on especially when
there's vested interests so I was
tweeting about this yesterday and I
tweeted that video out and a lot of
people just kept saying to me well the
whole you you believe in the system at
all like I don't believe in it at all is
that even more dangerous because then
that app like you have to believe in
something right like extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence
Carl Sagan right like you gotta believe
in signing so I can't just believe
everything's rigged and then just throw
my hands up right yeah a lot of it is
rigged but I feel like people use that
sometimes as an excuse to not vote yeah
and that's really sad because
politicians have to respond to some
degree to popular demand and if you
don't express what you want and what's
important to you how can you expect to
change anything you know so there's got
to be a little bit of hope there and
people have to be willing to actually
actively take part in politics and not
just be a spectator I can't end it any
better than that all right this week in
Isis it continues you know our air
strikes continue we didn't really talk
about it all week because of the
election but we're doing the air strikes
we don't seem to know if they're helping
or not actually most of the stuff that
I'm reading in the last week it sounds
like it's not helping at all but then
there was an interesting video posted by
Isis on YouTube where and it was
translated by Al Anon TV where a group
of Isis fighters are joking about the
girls that they now have sold into sex
slavery so let's take a look
okay so in some perverse way this
actually seems worse to me than the
beheading videos because the beheading
videos it's over right then and there
you see that it's over they are
literally selling these girls mostly
Yazidi girls into a lifetime of slavery
and god only knows what these guys are
gonna do with them pretty awful decisive
thing is not getting any better huh
there is no way at the end of the tunnel
there is nothing positive about this
there's nothing you can even spin to
make it humorous like this is tragic
it's it's it's nightmarish I mean the
fact that these women were one of these
women got a phone call into Peshmerga
soldier and actually requested that
somebody please bomb this this building
that they're being housed in to put them
out of their misery I mean it's beyond
devastating yeah
why aren't women's right
groups talking about this I am
fascinated by this because you know pink
pink code pink is one of these big
women's rights groups and they're
incredibly anti-war now I don't want a
war in the Middle East
I don't know that these bombs are doing
anything but it seems to me that women's
rights groups could should be protesting
this at least doesn't mean necessarily
that means we got to leave them to war
put soldiers there but where where are
women standing up for women right now I
just don't get it it's very frustrating
for me and this is something that I feel
like I keep going back to you but people
live in a bubble and they only focus on
what's going on right here
and that's really sad and and I looked
at the article about this and there were
only like four comments on it only four
and it just blew my mind because I've
been recently dealing with a lot of like
feminists versus anti-feminists like
hate wars on the line and stuff and like
you post one article about gamergate
where people are concerned that the
female you know trope or whatever's
being objectified and there's like
thousands of comments and people are
just outraged but then something like
this happens and it's like you hear
crickets
yeah is it partly because we just expect
that part of the world to be incredibly
backwards and sadly it just never fails
us right so if this was happening maybe
if this was happening in France if it
was happening the Western world
obviously we'd be more upset or there
would be more of an outrage I guess from
women but because we expect only
awfulness over there well then I I think
with this situation there has yet to be
a hashtag trending thing that's happened
I mean if you're looking to bring our
girls back that somebody created the
hashtag bring our girls back in Nigeria
you know and like then it became an
issue because the media supported it and
celebrities supported it that has yet to
happen here and I don't know if it's
because you know it's it's Isis and it's
frightening and it seems like the other
and they don't want to get involved I
think that there's this like looming
fear of Isis I mean as it should be it's
it's a scary organization but I feel
like people are just hands-off with it
you know they don't want to get involved
in it and it's intimidating so as smart
independent women doing your thing on
this planet I'm curious how you guys
feel like just at a personal level when
you watch that because I can watch it
and it's obviously horrific
I felt sick I'm off watching it just the
way they were talking about women like
there were some kind of thing to play
with you know oh I want the one with
green eyes I want the one with teeth you
know it's like I'll pay you you know
I'll give you a gun and you know return
for a person that's how they check their
cattle that they trade they look at
their teeth that's how they trade their
livestock and it's like to think of
these women just simply as that they're
the equivalent or even below really
livestock you know it's it's you can
either agree with you I literally feel
ill thinking about it because I go into
their mind and their lives and think
about just the lifetime ahead of them of
misery yeah all right well there's
obviously no pleasant way to wrap that
one up so at least be aware of it and be
aware of what's going on I guess and
hopefully something will change for the
better but let's stay in that part of
the world because things are not
changing for the better in Egypt
actually the last time that I had
Jacqueline and Whitney on we talked
about the seven Egyptian men that were
arrested after what was a gay wedding
actually it's obviously not legal there
but they were calling it a gay wedding
so let's just show you some footage from
the wedding itself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so when we did that story a month
ago seven men had been arrested now it
turns out that eight men are gonna go to
jail for three years with an additional
three years of probation
technically homosexuality is not illegal
in Egypt but you they are convicted on
charges of debauchery so it basically is
illegal you know we've sort of were just
talking about this with women in that
part of the world but where is the
outrage on this this story came out
about five days ago when it happened a
month ago and that thing was released I
barely heard anything now look what
they're doing in Russia with the
propaganda law obviously terrible we
started boycotting Stoli which is made
in Latvia actually not even Russia that
got everybody crazed but look what say
this is far worse actually where where's
the outrage where's the gay community
outrage let's start with the gays where
are the gays you know I think this goes
back to what I was saying earlier
there's something with the middle east
that people take this very hands-off
approach like they don't you know
there's not this trending support behind
it like there is in Russia because it's
it's not safe to them I think that
there's this in turn like real intrinsic
phobia when dealing with the Middle East
and issues and people just don't want to
get involved it's almost a status quo
like oh yeah that's just the Middle East
you know of course they're doing stuff
like this they don't think to try to
change it maybe we just need to come up
with a trendy hashtag it's like well
I've read comments below you know
various stories surrounding this and you
know a lot of people are saying exactly
what you said they're saying well what
do you expect from a country or from a
group of people that beheads people
publicly and it's like exactly they
expect this whole you know trickle down
of horrible inhumane acts who wants
there is a lot because they're not
beheading people in Egypt yeah it
doesn't matter what country it is the
people just clump the Middle East and
Muslims
no you can't just see like oh well since
it's to be expected I don't care about
it or I'm not ready to say anything
about Italy right and also were we
expecting that much better from Putin in
Russia that back got us upset I feel
like there's like it has something to do
with Putin himself like we're gonna do a
story on him in a second but like but
there something like it was like oh we
can attack this guy and it's very
obvious who the bad guy is we're here
it's just this like amorphous thing so
the gays need to do more obviously but
don't you like some sort of alliance of
like atheists and rational people and
something sort of [ __ ] can start it can
start with us but really with with gays
and scientists and atheists and this
rational group the group that before we
were talking about the election that I
said just doesn't really ever show up as
a unit to sort of be talking about these
things because to me this these are
liberal values that liberals have to
stand up for and it's like this is
either frame that is like the neo cons
want to go into the Middle East and
change it and make a democratic and they
don't want to be but then the people
that want to help these people the
Liberals just don't do [ __ ] like this is
important you know just getting the word
out there and getting people to be you
know more active and care and sometimes
you know you have to do things like this
and forums and get people involved
because honestly more people who are
talking about it the more power you have
in general because I mean I listen to
NPR all the time don't hear anybody talk
about it yeah what does that say about
the left I've been doing a lot of stuff
on this on my channel lately about how
the Left seems to be failing sort of by
not defending liberal principle what
does that say if NPR won't touch this
because they're going oh it's a lost
cause over there what does that say I
don't I really don't know what the
answer is I wish I knew too I feel like
I was looking to you for answers really
where I was looking for answers I I
don't know but I will be creating
hashtag today and it will
going viral yeah what do you think it
says about the left I mean honestly I
think it says more about the media and
you know the politics behind it than
what the left is actually standing for
because like I mean obviously we're all
you know how we all have like liberal
ideals and stuff and we care right now
so I think it's just about getting the
word out there and whether or not you're
able to do that easily well said all
right well let's sort of stick in the
Middle East because this does have a lot
to do with the Middle East but it
actually has a lot to do with some stuff
that's going on right here the UN is now
considering a ban on gay conversion so
we've got some info on gay conversion
for you the UN Committee Against Torture
has filed a shadow report on the subject
the shadow report focuses on the US and
urges every state to adopt legislation
or regulations prohibiting state
licensed professionals from attempting
to change a minors sexual orientation or
gender identity I'm going to tell you a
little bit more about what's going on in
America but first if the NCLR and its
allies are successful in having the UN
panel declare that anti-gay therapy is
torture it could have implications for
the US and other countries as
signatories of the Convention Against
Torture and other cruel inhuman or
degrading treatment or punishment treaty
it's possible that such nations could be
obliged as a matter of international law
not to allow the practice of sexual
orientation change efforts or prosecute
individuals that perform it so
interestingly here now first off there's
a lot of questions as to whether the UN
can actually do anything and they pass
all these resolutions and then not much
changes they've got awful countries on
human rights boards and all kinds of
nonsense that we talk a lot about but in
the United States right now forty-eight
of our states still allow gay conversion
therapy Michele Bachmann Michele
Bachmann's husband was a gay conversion
therapy Whitney do you have any jokes on
that one but when I when I saw this it
was making me think that maybe this is
more important for Americans to stand up
then even gay marriage at this point
because the gay marriage thing is
happened like basically now there's
going to be a mess in Florida because of
the new governor and Texas it's gonna
take a while your Florida
but it's pretty much happened and if you
live in America and you really want to
marry a saint the person of the same sex
you can go to a place and be treated
equally by the law but that this is much
more damaging because it's what it's
doing to young people right people need
to realize is that this is essentially
the equivalent of you know taking an
african-american kid putting them in a
camp and telling them that they need to
become white by the time they leave yeah
it it people need to realize that this
is not something that is by choice you
are born this way and and that's and
that's what it is it's the equivalent of
changing race or anything like that it's
it can't be done yeah so therefore it is
torture because it's impossible to
create another and it's also torture
because I mean look at the methods that
they use for their electroshock therapy
so they literally show that person so if
it's if it's a gay male they show that
person gay porn and then electrocute
them so that eventually give them drugs
or something to make them nauseous so
that they're actually throwing up and
physically ill at the sight of these
images and then of course they'll do the
opposite where they show them you know
heterosexual things and make them happy
or feel good or you know yeah touch them
inappropriately you know so it's just
that is torture so my code seems like it
totally blurred cross crosses blurred
lines between like you know mala station
and weirdness that goes on with that
right well it's also like all these
can't write these camps where they do
this and it's like these adults that are
obviously closeted and they're like how
do you how do you get past your gay
feelings you have to cuddle with me for
an hour while you tell me about your
sexual fantasies I mean really
disgusting stuff but what does it say
though about in America because this
seems to me like this would be going on
in the rest of world but it's still
happening here how would we not we got
the gay marriage thing going okay great
but how do we leave this like severely
damaging psychological thing in place I
mean that's that's a good question I I
don't know like it baffles me that that
is still going on today I mean it's
still going on because of the fact that
the people that are getting sent to
these camps are children and people that
are not spoken for you know gate with
gay marriage we're adults were outspoken
we have opinions were
taking action these are kids that don't
have an outlet they don't have somebody
to turn to they don't have help yeah
that's an interesting point so there's
something like not sexy about it I don't
know that's a bad word I suppose but
like something about like gay marriage
you can see adults there's something
there's a way to frame it that seems
mature as I am this it's so gross
actually spoken I mean just for being an
unknown thing you know these conversion
camps I think the the people that know
about it are the parents that want to
put their kids in it you know it's not
something that's really discussed
outside of that because you know people
those people are adults and they're
embracing their sexuality and they're
working towards gay marriage but they're
forgetting about you know the youth that
are getting put into these these are
actually that's what it's supposed to
come in because this is child abuse you
know they should not have the ability to
do that to their children so obviously
the problem lies with the government not
having stricter regulations on this I
can't believe they're so allowing it but
also we need to focus on the parents and
the mentality that goes behind creating
this type of thing to begin with yeah so
there's definitely been a theme to this
show between government and religion and
saying but this must be one of those
things that drives you particularly
crazy right because the the conversion
people most of this I would venture to
say that probably 95% of it is based in
religion somehow or across the board
it's all the religions I know everybody
wants to pick a religion you hate that
religion all the religions do this awful
conversion [ __ ] so this must be
something that particularly drives you
nuts because it shows how the government
and religion are still so intertwined
not the separation of church and state
that there needs to be and it's just an
yet another example of how religion
poisons everything yeah speaking of
religion poisoning everything is
religion poison Instagram because that
would cause people to go completely
bonkers you may have seen this Chelsea
Handler posted a picture nude on a horse
now she did this on Instagram how not
new topless on a horse and she did this
as homage to that famous picture of
Vladimir Putin on the horse that we've
all seen so here's the picture that she
originally put up on Instagram and now
we've put that red bar there so she did
it she was fully topless with no blur
out or anything and she did this now
that's against instagrams Terms of
Service now we've put it there because
also to show nipple to show female
nipple would be again
YouTube's Terms of Service were on
YouTube and now I know this could be
offensives for some other people so we
did add another bar because I didn't
want it so there you go
we Whitney I knew that was yeah I know
that was gonna offend Whitney
particularly so now we blocked out all
nipples so everyone watching this should
be okay because we know the nipple is
scary and okay so then after that
Instagram took it down and Chelsea
Handler was not happy so let's take a
look at her next Instagram posting she
posted what Instagram sent to her we've
removed your post because it doesn't
follow our community guidelines again
this was the stuff about nudity now what
she wrote beneath it which you can see
at the bottom there she says if a man
posts a photo of his nipples it's okay
but not a woman
are we in 1825 okay now let's look at
her next Instagram post she did it again
she doubled down and said I'm gonna try
this again and again it was without our
fancy red bar right there and Instagram
once again oh and she wrote on the
bottom if Instagram takes this down
again you're saying Vladimir Putin has
more First Amendment rights than me talk
to your bosses and of course what
Instagram do they took that down after
55 minutes so I think there's a lot of
interesting stuff here first off no
thanks necessary for getting rid of
boobies nipples you know Twitter is the
one that allows nudity I've had to
unfollow some people that occasionally
we're posting nudity because every now
Hugh Jackman because no because every
now and again if I if I'm flipping on
Twitter publicly and some weird nude
thing comes up like I can't have that
popping up but apparently someone told
me there is a filter to even get that
out the way but the point is that
Facebook doesn't allow it YouTube
doesn't allow it instagram doesn't how
twitter does allow it look we live in a
time where everyone's naked stuff is out
there and webcams and all that stuff so
are these sites just behind the times
like what is Instagram I'm really trying
to prove here I don't know if sites are
being at the time like I you know I love
men okay I love you you're great but
this is like a weird man thing that goes
on here because like I'm a lesbian I'm
into chicks I'm into chicks bodies but
the fact is like
boobs don't like wow me in terms of
being like a hot sexual like they're
just boobs you know so this has to be
some weird Freudian I wrote right here
what's the deal with boobs that's gonna
be question number three it has to be
some weird like Freudian man thing where
they like I don't know if if men and
feel some weird protection over it
because they were like nursed from these
boobs
I mean I need to know what it is because
it's really just a fat sack and that
doesn't sound hot at all like you know
back with a nipple I'm gonna be hip
question number two I'm gonna go right
to question number three what's the deal
with boobs I mean really think about
this now yeah go ahead
I I don't get it like I mean I I agree
with you it is just a sack of fat with a
nipple that's really not that different
from a man yeah why do women have to be
censored when men don't I think it's
very strange so I I agree with what
she's saying and it's great that she's
trying to make that point but if she's
gonna go the First Amendment route I
mean Instagram is technically a business
of its own they're allowed to have their
own rules and policies and if that's
against their guidelines it's against
their guidelines you know so for her to
say it's a violation of her First
Amendment right it isn't necessarily
true and plus I don't think Putin was
ever really benefiting from those to
begin with so just to be very clear
you're a hundred percent right it's not
a violation of the First Amendment
because it's not the government coming
in and stopping this the company is
allowed to do it and if someone else
wants to put an app on the Apple Store
that allows that you know the nipple app
and the boob app then go ahead so this
isn't a First Amendment issue it's a
political correctness issue or something
like that like I've seen men with like
many men with larger breasts than mine
you know I don't know what's that saying
about me and they can put an Instagram
you know like I just I don't get it yeah
so to them to the boob point now if it
seems to me that if if they had shown
that her boobs if they had exposed her
nipples
it actually would have been fine out and
people would have been excited you know
her fans would have been happy but it
would have been alright now there is a
fundamental difference I think this is
what you were going for between showing
a boob pic and
and either showing a dick pic and a
vagina picture can we make that this
Jacqueline can you make that distinction
that maybe that's a fair line to draw
yeah we're all agreed on that at least
you can be like oh I get like not
showing a vagina or a dick pic because
like those two things go together in
some way and can be sexual you know I'm
saying like it can be considered
sexualized items but like boobs they're
just it's a fetish sized item like it's
not a real sexual thing it's amazing you
know and and you know people were making
comments about well women get implants
and there's things surrounding em you
know what go in West Hollywood there's
calf implants everywhere I don't see
like little red bars over men's calves
and picture is right so in terms of the
the sites and Twitter and Instagram and
all these other things you know everyone
says the tumblers become like the porn
home and they deny it and when Yahoo
bought them they were like oh there's no
porn on there we don't know anything
about that but eventually these things
will turn right because no one's not on
Twitter because there's the potential
for porn right apparently I need to look
at Twitter more because I'm either like
who do you follow that you had this
barrage
Deepak Chopra like that actually it was
well I have to say this has been very
titillating conversation waka waka okay
let's move on science the science not
come up with something every week that
you just can't believe now some
scientists are saying that atheists do
not actually exist believe it or not I
thought I was sitting here with one but
apparently not let's look at some info
cognitive scientists are becoming
increasingly aware that a metaphysical
outlook may be so deeply ingrained in
human thought processes that it cannot
be expunged Jaclyn I'm gonna have you
clean that up for us in a minute some
scientists are claiming the atheism is
psychologically impossible because of
the way humans think we've got a little
more they point to studies showing that
even people who claim to be committed a
guests tacitly hold religious beliefs
such as the existence of an immortal
soul scientists say we are born
believers not atheists humans are
patterned seekers from birth with a
belief in karma or cosmic justice as our
default setting I brought my favorite
atheist here and her head is in her
hands so much take it away atheist you
don't exist I mean how am I even here
right now I don't know it's a miracle
whenever I was reading this article III
noticed one of the very first things it
said in quotes scientists discover
atheists don't exist that was like
really oh wow that's an interesting fact
I wonder what test they did for that but
I mean this is just like I've heard this
so many times you can't really be an
atheist there's got to be something deep
down inside that tells you there's a God
and I hear it from atheist too like they
don't believe that anyone can really be
a Christian like deep down you know it's
all [ __ ] right you know like it's so
frustrating to you that it's like why
can't people just accept that certain
people have certain beliefs I don't you
know some people do and I'm never like
well duped out you obviously don't
really believe it I'm sure they do you
know and in the same way some people
just don't believe in God and I
understand what they're saying about the
evolutionary you know benefit because
you know this goes back to the whole
like if you hear a noise in the woods
you know do you run from it or do you
think oh there's nothing there you know
it's beneficial to assume that there is
something there because if there were
obviously you would be killed or eaten
or whatever and then you know you
wouldn't be able to survive and
reproduce and you know survival of the
fittest and there forth so I mean I get
it but that mentality can be overcome
you know with science when we actually
have facts and things you know that we
can look to and understand how things
work instead of just assuming yeah is
there anything science can do that would
prove these heathens like her that God
exists do you think science could ever
prove to her
literally makes me want to smash my face
into this table because I can't wrap my
head I'm like I feel crazy think about
it because working well because it's so
like I mean first of all it's physically
it's impossible to say that it's
impossible to be born like this you know
because we don't know because you're
influenced from birth and it's it's all
about influence and what you've been you
know raised to believe and nature
nurture things that affect you this also
this study seems like it is more
westernized like the the people that
were putting it together or from like a
Western culture did they go to like
tribal Africa and see or different
things where different aspects and
corners of the world where you know
there's different possibilities of how
people are affected by their
surroundings that's what I'm curious
about because this just seems like the
those specific people can't wrap their
heads around it like I said so it seems
to me that the the main push that
they're saying here is what I'm sure you
hear all the time that there are no
atheists in a foxhole that that seems to
be what they're saying that there's some
evolutionary purpose why at the end of
the day you know if you know that this
is it you would you would I don't know
force yourself to believe or something
you must hear that constantly right that
that at the end of the day when it's
over for you and you're in your last
moments you're going to accept what is
inevitable or something that's so
frustrating that's and it's it's so rude
you know and it's it's such an insult
because it's pretty much saying
everything that you may think is
important especially in my case this is
what I do and people have said it to me
so when they say that to me they're
pretty much saying you aren't smart
enough to actually believe what you're
you know your convictions you actually
can't stand behind those things and at
the end of the day I'm sure you would
flop because you can't really believe it
because your thoughts are and there's no
way beyond the tree falls in the woods
make any noise you know like it's
impossible to prove any of this yeah no
it must be totally maddening
but it has ever come back and say like
it seems to me that you could just as
easily say to a religious person well
maybe at the end when you're laying
there in your last moments you've spent
your whole life being religious
believing this certain set of beliefs
and you as you whatever happens at the
end that we obviously none of us know
and there's no proof of any of it that
maybe you realize it was all cool shapes
[Music]
you know like really like isn't that
like couldn't do you ever use that
argument with them I don't because it's
such a stupid I have so much you know
else I can say that's just so much
stronger than why would I you know waste
it on our I'm not gonna stoop but like
at the same time like I get it why white
people say that to a degree just because
like whenever you are sick or if you're
in your last moments you know positivity
sometimes can help people last a little
bit longer you know but for me or and
I'm for a lot of atheists like you can
have that without religion it is
possible yeah so that actually is a
perfect segue to my next question do you
believe in like horoscopes and karma and
all that kind of stuff so that even some
of the stuff that has some sort of like
a horoscope has some sort of scientific
something-or-other right is there no
like something because the sign in the
moon and the thing with the and that
dial and what about that Wow
alright I guess I'll have to cross that
off where are you are you an atheist
what am I gonna do I enjoy a good
horoscope now and again mainly because I
don't want to base my decisions off of
my the results of my actions off of
decisions I've made yeah I like the
blame it on other things you know you
know that's the thing I really like to
displace blame of my life side women
horoscopes
a higher power my wife yeah the big
three yeah yeah I don't know lie to me I
believe in the force I've said this a
thousand times I believe there's
something happening but it can either
sort of be used for good or sorry to be
used for bed does that even drive you
crazy when someone says something like
that I mean honestly I'm not that kind
of person where I'm offended
every little thing yeah I don't really
care but if you ask me if I believe in
it I don't yeah but you do believe I'm a
Jedi that's that yeah really solve this
like alright one more for you there is a
new sex survey out and yeah you are a
sexual deviant you freak that's right
there is a lot of stuff going on here
the Journal of Sexual Medicine published
some interesting findings and we've got
some of them for you right here so
researchers from the University of
Montreal presented 799 men and 718 women
I'm always curious where they come up
with those numbers 85% of whom
identified as heterosexual 4% homosexual
and 11% somewhere in between so there's
a lot of by people I guess with a long
list of statements regarding fantasy
scenarios asking them to rate their
agreement with each on a scale of one to
seven anything rated over three was
counted as a fantasy and let's look at
the results
okay so men are in green females are in
blue pretty much equal on the group sex
everybody's sort of feeling group sex
equally not a ton of people are into it
but everyone kind of likes it females
now in a certain spot yeah we had a
little debate I don't even know what
that means they say do you like having
sex in a certain spot or were they like
do you like having sex you know on the
couch or did eight men well in here I
actually have an answer for you because
they did ask them they wanted to open
was a specific location they didn't ask
them which location it was whether it
was an airport or something of that
nature but they just where they want to
have in a specific spot let's look back
with the stranger so females want to
have sex with the stranger so we're just
gonna plow through this no pun intended
and that here's the fascinating one
males a lot of males are fantasizing
about having anal not just having it
receiving racemic anal men to pay
attention to
because this graph here because this
just shows that men think that anal sex
is a good thing to have so I would just
like to show that based on that small
chunk of blue women don't agree maybe
they don't usually agree you know you're
giving us a real interesting view into
your sex life and finally as far as
receiving oral sex men do think about
that a lot they also think about you
know but they do think about receiving
or a lot women think about receiving
oral less okay so there's some
interesting stuff there does anything I
guess the anal sex thing the men
receiving anal sex that seems to be the
one that's surprising us is that the one
that's the big one out of it
I mean I'm personally not really
surprised that my occupations I've had
to do this but no yeah I think that I
have had occupations that no yeah I mean
I don't know if it's it's surprising I I
want to see like the other really really
surprising like was there anything on
there that was like real shocking I
looked over it as a graph and I wanted
to see if there was like huge
discrepancies between like men and women
on things and there was nothing like
super surprising I feel like everybody's
kind of right did you see I mean the the
sex with a stranger part was just a what
do you make that's okay it makes me seem
like this like one of those staunch Bay
Area lesbians nice I mean I feel like
maybe they're like fantasizing about
having sex with people that are not
their husbands that are satisfying them
okay so I mean I don't even know that
that's a lesbian theory I think that's
just pretty
theory I just feel like you will blame
it on the fact that I'm law here it's
the stranger it's a thing like I can get
it like if maybe if you're in a
relationship you're fantasizing about
you know Joe Smith from work or like
ex-celebrity
you know but to say like a stranger
that's just a little bit like because
you're creating like somebody that's
like really
fulfilling all of your fantasies is this
thing just basically a sort of
condemnation of straight men that's what
it seems to be right because straight
men are very afraid of doing anything
with their body that's that's one thing
and this thing about the women wanting a
second strategy it's sort of like
because there is just straight guys are
just kind of boring and I'm gonna get a
lot of hate into you in the comment
section I know it's coming but that
women are just like looking at the guy
that they're with and they're like this
guy is so boring and so out of shape and
so but that I would like to censor the
perfect stranger that would do it more
more than even just fantasy about the
guy that I work with people need to look
at this and have an open conversation
about the fact that maybe women just
need to start having anal sex with men
at the top that could be satisfying all
the way around men will be happy woman
will probably be happy because they're
getting something out of it finally
whether it be like a power struggle yeah
you know Jacqueline wanna have sex in
those in a bizarre place is there a
place I mean sure that sounds like I
mean like I'm open to certain things
with what your thought I mean some of it
but like the stranger thing does not
does not sound like fun to me no
stranger is really just people when they
ask that if people are just thinking
someone other than my significant other
than I'm with in an intimate setting
that makes more sense
but it did say stranger so I'm but I
mean honestly like I like this whole
article because like I feel like people
are so scared to talk about sex you know
like they're so uptight about it and
especially like even the women and stuff
that they were interviewing you know
giving these answers and stuff and you
know even though I personally don't you
know drive with the whole stranger thing
like if that's something that you know
turns on other woman good for you talk
about it be open about it don't be
afraid don't be afraid of what people
are gonna call you or if people are
going to judge you you know like be open
about people are so afraid to talk about
sex
I agree don't we need more I mean even
this little four-minute discussion that
were having don't we need more of this
on TV like you see all these people I
always think this when I'm watching like
election coverage last night I know
you're watching like these 20 people
that you know all their political
opinions but like at the end of the day
if I like at the end of the day this
wolf blitzer want to be tied up and peed
on you're like that would vote more
clearly I would vote you know with more
faith if I knew their sexual practices
listen to their political opinions if I
knew that Paul Begala wants give me
something good here we both went to pee
which have been interested in what goes
on in the bedroom for a long time so
about time we start talking about it out
final thought on this have you ever
encountered anyone that wanted to do
something really freaky sexual that you
just blew your mind you're like I can't
be part of this oh you've got something
I mean I I may or may not have briefly
dated someone who was far more
interested in my feet than I would have
liked a little strange but that ended
very quickly so it's okay Glenn their
twitters are down below follow them on
the Facebook's and the instagrams maybe
to get some nipples you never know and I
subscribe and all that good stuff and
we'll see you next week Thanks
[Music]